we can confirm uh nazanin zagari
radcliffe and anush ashori will return
to the uk today this is coming from the
uh foreign secretary liz truss as she
has tweeted this she also says that
morale tapas
has been released from prison on
furlough they will be reunited with
their families later today that's
talking about nazanin zagari radcliffe
and anusha ashori
but they will continue to work to secure
morad's departure from iran so
nazanin zagari radcliffe has been
released
from iran it is confiscal official and
the prime minister has also tweeted he
says
i am very pleased to confirm that the
unfair detention of nazanin zagari
radcliffe and anusha ashuri in iran has
ended today and they will now return to
the uk
he has also said that the uk has worked
intensively to secure the release of
sagari radcliffe
and he's delighted that they will be
reunited with their families and their
loved ones so we thought that they
potentially were in the air we thought
that they had been taken to tehran
airport but it is now official